hey guys I'm Jess McDonald it's the 16th
of April and you're tuned into gamespot
news square enix is defending drm today
and predictably it's not going down so
well with you guys Square Enix business
manager Adam Sullivan told torrentfreak
that digital rights management systems
are a necessary part of doing business
to prevent piracy and increase profit
although he does say the key to DRM is
that it can't interfere with the
customers ability to play the game it's
not uncommon for people to get new
computers every few years or to have
multiple computers sometimes they don't
have reliable internet connections
there's no perfect solution yet Sullivan
went on to say that he thinks DRM is
here to stay and will be essential for
the foreseeable future do you guys agree
with Sullivan or how commenters like
diamond dog X who says if you treat your
customers with respect and as customers
you might actually term some pirates
into customers and keep the customers
you already have happy as they aren't
treated like pirates then there's master
underscored turismo who quite rightly
points out CD Projekt RED says otherwise
let me know your thoughts and the week's
not getting a whole lot better for
Square Enix as sony has now decided to
sell its entire stake in the company
valued at 47 million dollars sony
announced the news in a japanese press
release stating that all 9.5 two million
shares would be unloaded it's suspected
that this is simply the latest in sony's
efforts to return to profitability after
planning to sell to major office
buildings laying off thousands of
employees and selling its pc division
according to The Wall Street Journal
Sony held 8.2 percent of Square Enix's
total shares if you just found three
dollars and you're into call of duty
ghosts then maybe you won't snoop dogg
announcing your kills because that's now
a thing you can get the three dollar dlc
will feature voiceover work from the
famous rapper where he says things like
squad member active a brother from
another mother and ballistic vest ready
those are some fine ass threads not only
are these statements serving to make me
sound even more white than i already am
they're specifically called snoop is
to allow Snoop to add his own flair to
the pre-written lines from developer
Infinity Ward commenting on the
partnership mr. dog said what interests
me most about the project is that my
voice could be connected to a game
that's so hip and so hood it says a lot
it's associated with greatness on top of
his addition to the game on April 22
there will also be a drill instructor
voice pack launching voice bye ollie
Urmi better known as the drill sergeant
from the film full metal jacket if you
couldn't give a toss about voice work
but you're into call of duty there are
also some character and weapon
specialization packs launching that you
can check out let me know in that
commenting section down below which
celebrity you'd most like to see
featured in a game or you can chat to me
directly on my Twitter where I'm at just
McDonald that is it for me today and in
australia this week we have a four day
weekend so the lovely chris waters will
be filling in for me for the next couple
of days so i can galavant and hit up
some cool parties ok I'll be playing
wolf among us and Diablo but I'll see
you on Monday